[Music]  hey it's shawn mendes the voice of lyle  tonight  we're so excited for you to see the new  trailer for our new movie lyle crocodile  watch it now  i have no idea what that was  new york city did we just move here i  think we did you think josh is going to  be okay  this is my crocodile  let's take good care of him  josh time to wake up come on  he's not dangerous he's crocodile he's  just lonely like me hey you awake yet he  can't talk but he can sing  at the top of the world tonight  when no one ever has to hide  what everybody get out of here there's a  crocodile in the house  this could not be happening we have a  crocodile  do you realize how different things have  been since i met him  you changed everything for me  not just for me for youtube  we have to show people that they don't  have to be afraid  crocodile on a motorcycle  baby there's nothing holding me back  [Music]  bye